do you ever like think back like
man what if we would have just all
been on the same page the kind of run
you guys could have had are you happy
with
where your journey has led you we would
have surely been going crazy but like it
was a lot of [ __ ] going on like
i feel everybody probably happier like
how [ __ ] is right now like i'm happy
i know slimy happy
i'm pretty sure everybody else happy
like you feeling me we all happy like
you families
like
everybody uh was i gonna say like
uh
to me for me i'm gonna speak for myself
like i feel more refreshing like you fam
there's a lot of [ __ ] i ain't gotta deal
with you feeling me
[ __ ] more refreshing i can focus you
feel me worry about me you only have
yeah well now you have to only worry
about what you want and
now you could tell your story without
having to worry about you know i feel
like that's the one thing about being in
a group is like there's always a
compromise with the creativity you know
one [ __ ] could say some stupid ass [ __ ]
and like you feeling me everybody name
tied to it like you fam
i'm
refreshing like i'm good like
i used to be stressed out like hell and
[ __ ] like [ __ ] i stressed out like no
nothing like i'm good like